all right how about the UNLV Rebels  turning a few heads now they're only a  few plays away from being 3-0 on this  season but they lost in the final  minutes at Cal with two home wins under  the belts now they're off to Utah state  with a team that's feeling pretty  confident they're starting to believe in  the process good to see our guys come  out and rebound from uh from week two  um return from Cal on the road with a  little bit of a gut punch there to see  our guys come back and rally in front of  our our home fans and uh and to play a  good football team it's been together a  long time and to really play that way  like I said after the game the style of  the play to see to see guys take care of  the football to start fast attack well  do good on third down zero penalties on  defense got a few we can take back on  offense ran the ball really physically  physical finish the game explosive plays  all right